the head coach of lipscomb academy
football in the great state of tennessee
and uh super bowl champion and one of my
favorite people i've gotten to meet uh
in my time in the nfl uh on the
mercedes-benz vans phone line our friend
trent dilfer how are you trent
rich how are we doing buddy better for
talking to you man how's everything with
you how's everything
good getting ready for our uh
quarterfinal matchup tonight okay who
who are we beating tonight trent who we
beat uh a place called silverdale out of
chattanooga tennessee okay
don't say that don't put him in that
position come on he's the head coach
here i'm trying to hype him up okay well
we're hyped up for you man we're hyped
up thank you you're fun you're welcome
well thanks for taking the time on on a
game day to do this um how do you see
odell well let's start let's say the
first thing why didn't odell work in
cleveland best you can tell
trent
um he was banged up part of the time i
think the offense isn't structured for a
player like odell how so uh what do you
mean by that
stuff and i like by the way i'm not
criticizing
i actually think it's a pretty good way
to play to win on offense for
complimentary football a lot of times
you have kind of dude based offenses
where you're going to get the dudes the
ball no matter what you're gonna
compromise some of your core values as a
team
uh as an offense just try to feed the
hungry right odell's hungry he wants to
be fed all the time
uh and that works like if you're wide
open if you're gonna throw it a lot if
you don't really care about getting the
runners going getting your offensive
line going downhill time of possession
metrics things like that that's a great
way to play fans love it it puts up
points
a lot of old school coaches will tell
you it's not a winning formula the fancy
comes from kind of an old school lineage
of offensive football
theirs is more system base it's more
um they're gonna they're gonna dictate
terms the run game and the action game
and the perimeter guys are gonna fall
into place based on how the defense
plays you so you're not drawing up ball
plays to get the ball to receivers
you're drawing the ball plays to
puncture the inside of the defense get
your second level to activate get your
tight ends inside players in between the
hashes the ball and then if the defense
starts reacting to that now you get the
ball outside to your quote-unquote dudes
again one's not better than the other
it's just philosophical differences on
how nfl
coaches call office
um i think that's one of the reasons i
think baker is a guy that needs to be he
needs to be system driven he's a system
quarterback that's not a knock either
there's very few that aren't system guys
there's very few that are transcendent
um system transcendent uh baker is a
system guy he needs he needs to play the
position as much like drew brees as
possible get the ball of his hand in the
passing game and take his shots in the
action game
again you're not going to have a lot of
volume to odell when you do things like
that so i know these are esoteric kind
of long-winded answers but that's the
that's the reality of the nfl that the
fan doesn't understand that you are all
part of a system and if you don't fit
that system you're not going to put the
numbers you would have in the system
prior that you were in when you put a
big number so then i mandated it before
moving on about
what the system is with the rams and how
it works for odell to ask you for browns
fans do you think that the what what's
the fans he's bringing is what is the
system that baker needs do you think
that's all i think i with the ram are
you asking me what it's going to look
like in the ram no before we get to that
just lingering about the system you
talked about with stefanski and how
baker needs a system uh is this the
right one for him in your estimation
baker yes sir yes i think this is
perfect for him and i think stevansky's
very smart he knows who he has he's got
a very very high quality starting
quarterback in the nfl he does not have
a superman and when you don't have a
superman
or a superhero uh allah holmes rogers
uh
lamar tyler murray
um russell wilson there's probably a
couple others then your system you need
to call plays and build everything you
do around your quarterback because
you're trying to enhance your
quarterback with every play that you
call
um
and i think stephanie's doing it
perfectly high volume run game action
pass efficiency in the passing game they
need to get better in critical
situations third down red zone
uh and the gang stuff that comes with
time for quarterbacks i think he will
naturally be better at that uh the one
the the big
argument to the way stefanski plays the
way mike shanahan called plays the way
kyle shanahan calls plays kubiak you go
down that whole tree
is can you throw your team back
into a game from a two score deficit
and that's really the counter punch to
this
style of offense is great it sounds
awesome it works it's
tried and tested
but
very rarely do you throw your team back
from a two score deficit and i get that
i mean you look at these wide open
offenses we've never seen more two score
comebacks than we have in the last five
years
a lot of it's because teams are moving
away from this philosophy and playing
more wide open all right so then now
let's move to odell in in uh mcvay's
system do you like it what do you think
how's it gonna work
i like it but i don't see big volume i
don't see odell being a volume guy he's
being a big play guy i think it's a yard
yards per um
reception metric if you're gonna look at
from a numbers standpoint
odell's not a burner but he's an
incredible deep threat he's very fast
i'm not saying he's not fast but his
real gift is his ability to adjust to
the ball while it's in the air and this
is something i'm always trying to teach
people in football
deep receivers is not speed okay
uh there's a lot of fast guys now you
get a tyre kill that's different i mean
that's beep road rudder speed right
but there's a lot of guys in that four
four to four five five really really
fast if somebody says four five five
isn't fast you go time the fastest guys
on lasers and most of them are gonna be
the low four fives on a laser
so you're talking four four
to four five five that is real speed
that is nfl speed
um
just because they run fast doesn't mean
they're deep threats
a deep threat is a guy that can get to
top speed quickly
but then adjust to the ball in the air
and think about just in the simplest
form if you caught a fly ball right if
somebody hits you you're out there with
your kid and you pop a ball up and he's
got all this he's 12 years old he has
all this time to kind of get underneath
the ball and judge it and the arc of it
and get his feet underneath it and catch
it and then you just rip a line drive to
your 12 year old
well he's not gonna have time to adjust
to it right he's gonna whoa that thing's
gonna go right by him or unless you rip
it perfectly like you probably would he
just puts his glove up and catches it
thank you
so a deep threat receiver is a guy can
do both
he's a guy that can catch a fast tempo
ball down the field and adjust to a
lobby ball a 45 yard or 55 55-yard
sideline post
and while that boy balls aaron please
watch this fan because tv is so good now
you get these great replays especially
all 22s watch the angle they start at
and then they're as they're tracking the
ball watch how they can maintain top
speed and then adjust their bodies and
adjust their angles to the ball
adjust their eyes
time up their hands time up their feet
all these different things it takes to
be a great deep ball receiver
it's more than just speed odell is
phenomenal at this he adjusts to a ball
any tempo of a ball
as well as anybody i evaluated when he
came out
uh that doesn't go away he's gonna be a
massive deep threat i still think cups
gonna be the the volume guy they still
need to run the football uh woods is
more your uh space guy more your hybrid
uh van jefferson's a good player but i
think he gives van jefferson a chance to
kind of develop a little bit more
uh but i think odell is going to be guy
you're not going to see him catching a
ton of hitches i think you're going to
see slants the score and big balls trent
dilfer here on the rich eisen show uh
uh week 10 begins on thursday night
football again you're kind of my tua
whisperer i know you've been around the
kid forever we've been talking about him
for years
what what do you think
are the dolphins handling him properly i
know that's a that's a loaded question
potentially but i want to ask it because
it just seems you know with with kicking
tires on desean watson uh twice
pre-season mid-season owner meeting him
doesn't start banged up finger comes in
um wins a game
what does it all mean
do you think they're handling him
properly in miami yeah i don't have a
problem with that i mean listen to sean
watson aside from the legal stuff and i
think that's been well documented if you
can get that those things settled i
think there's 20 teams that are kicking
the tire or wanted to kick the tires
onto sean i mean he's a he's a
generational talent he's one of the best
what he was playing is one of the best
players in the league he was up for the
mvp
in discussion early last year i mean
he's a guy that everybody wants
um
i
i don't let's take the disarm thing out
of it yeah i kind of like how they're
handling the best move they made as an
organization was bringing charlie fry
into their coaching staff charlie cries
one of the
great young football minds in all of
football um
he has really been the glue of that
offense that's
got all that cool stuff they were
talking about last night so i watched
more of the thursday night game last
night i'm watching any thursday night
game and i was like wow they're doing
some cool stuff on offense even in the
run game because they're not very good
run of the football but they're trying
to find ways to find creases in the run
game and you can hear troy and
you can hear troy start to say
man some of this stuff's pretty cool
well that's pretty creative oh look what
they did here then they run the cool
little trick play
and
you know they're doing some stuff
offensively
that is pretty creative and and pretty
uh fun to watch they're just not great
right they got what 12 27 tight ends in
waddle
and you don't even know the running
backs names i mean they don't have a ton
of offensive weaponry to deal with so
they're they're scratching and clawing
trying to be the best offense they can
be and they want to play efficiently and
he played efficiently with a bad finger
uh he made some big plays in the fourth
quarter um push the ball down the field
i think as much as he can right now you
can definitely see that there's a lack
of horsepower right now with the finger
and then it got banged up again but yeah
i like how they're handling them they're
trying to salvage this season they're
building an identity of defense special
teams and an efficient offense they're
not going to be explosive this year
maybe not next year but maybe in a
couple years as they start drafting more
towards offense they got kaseki waddle
they need a couple more and i think they
can be a pretty darn good offense do you
think it too is going to be there do you
think it's his future i don't again at
this point things have gone so weird
with the deshawn situation i don't know
i mean i know they like them internally
they like them a lot do they love them
are they dating them or are they married
to them and now that's the question we
have for all these young quarterbacks as
they hit their third year fourth year
are you dating them are they the hot
blonde that kind of you know you don't
really mesh personality wise but you
want to take her on a date
or are they your wife like mine of 29
years that's hot and smart and a great
mom and all this stuff you know and i'm
like i'm married like i please don't
leave right
right so that's that's how these
organizations talk about their
talk about their their quarterbacks are
they cassandra dilfer who's a 10 in
every which way
we want to marry this we're going to pay
you as much as we can we're going to
build organization around you please
don't leave me or are they the hot
blonde that you're like yeah she's cute
nice instagram picture fun movie went to
a nice dinner
but we have nothing in common you know
so if she moves on that's fine
you know i think that's kind of to dumb
it down to its simplest form that's the
conversation within organizations
and so charlie fry's great mind uh was
that his uh design uh screen pass to the
right guard uh too i don't know i don't
wanna you know god sees a good good
coach they have other good coaches i i
know that charlie and two are very
connected yeah i know that most this
creativity and you can just see it when
you look at trends uh when you start
seeing jet motions and zone reads and
rpos and unique trick plays and specials
that has charlie fry written all over it
but i'm sure it's collective uh within
the offensive staff they kind of do it
like jim harbaugh does it at michigan
like some coaches do it where it's a
it's a collective effort offensively
there may be a guy with a coordinator
title
but they're all kind of piecing it
together but you definitely have known
charlie forever i played with them i
brought him into 11 you know groomed
them
um you can see his offensive in fact you
can go to central michigan paul plays
music coordinator and you saw him last
night for the dolphins they worked
remember when they ran that fake run
play tight end coming across the
formation hit them in the flat they this
fly motion where they got the guy down
the sideline because baltimore wasn't
adjusting to the fly motion and they got
the receiver down the left sideline like
those are all things he's been doing for
years he's very very very creative in
the run rpo action game now i wasn't
trying to
drag you into another problem in south
florida for the coaching staff trent
well i was i was making a cute reference
to the robert hunt uh right guard uh oh
that's one that was fantastic how
athletic is that kid man i mean
have you ever seen anything like that
like he was turned like he was he he
looked like he was the eligible receiver
and poor gaskin could have gotten it
i've never seen anything like it my
entire life it's so funny because it
happens in practice all the time does it
remember yeah when you're a slow screen
team and that's that play is it's a slow
screen every team nfl has a version of
it
most any old school coaching staff has a
slow screen a lot of the new staffs have
the fast screens but any slow screen
where you're releasing guard center
tackles pass protecting trying to get
the end to go buy them they they come
out together and the way you teach it is
guard center come out you you're almost
hip to hip and you want to get to the
railroad tracks and then you want to get
vertical well every time in practice
whenever there's a stunt or something
happens on defense line the guard or the
center gets kind of kicked back and the
quarterback he's not experienced he's
just gonna throw it to a spot you see it
hit the guard in the helmet you see it
hitting in the chest you know the
guard's not flat enough i mean slow
screens are hard to execute at a high
level now i've never seen a guard
go out get kicked backwards and turn
around like well i'll just catch the
ball i'm not necessarily the railroad
track so i'll just catch the ball and
then i'll go run with the ball that was
crazy it's almost as if he told his
buddies hey if i get held up getting out
on the screen i'm just going to catch
the sucker and run
and get cartwheel and reach out for the
i was just he's living his best life man
i
i love that uh hey last one for you um i
i this one's this one's a little
personal trent the
jets who is mike white what is mike
white and is it entirely possible that
that that that he's the answer and not
zach wilson you're here and now hey you
know robert salas like he isn't it's not
awkward it's awesome it's basically what
he's saying right now what do you what
do you think from afar
you're the i've been actually thinking
about this one a lot okay um because i
saw white play at western kentucky i
thought it was pretty good i i really
thought it was pretty good now he didn't
really fit where the nfl was going zac
fits where the nfl is going with a
highly athletic kind of
um
creative artistic quarterback
mike's kind he's a good athlete but he's
your traditional just kind of like sit
in the pocket rip fire trunk yardage
plays make quick decisions you know that
kind of guy
and i thought of he schuler gus ferrar
and i was drafted that same year
so heath went number three the redskins
i went six to tampa and then gus went in
the seventh round of the redskins
and those and i was in that draft i'm
like gus is as good as heath and i
like i saw gus play in college i'm like
why is he going in the seventh round
he's every bit as good as heath and i
he just didn't have this glamorous
college career
and i'm kind of thinking this could end
up
if mike plays well in the big apple and
jets lowest like you start jumping on
the bandwagon which you should right the
guy plays well he gets an opportunity
right he's winning games you should be
all over it
um
why can't this be gus for uh he schuler
and we don't hear about zach wilson you
know he plays few years in the nfl and
then off in the sunset mike white's the
quarterback it's very possible i mean
you teach these quarterbacks from the
time they're 14 years old control what
you can control and when you get an
opportunity you make the most of it and
mike white's the the poster boy for
getting an opportunity here and making
the most of it well the problem is
though is that the jets don't need i
mean gus ferrar god bless him and he had
a nice nice run and he's more known for
hitting his head and you know hurting
his neck you know in celebration to be
honest with you trent like
jets need the generational talent they
need they need the guy that you're
talking about mahomes that sort of thing
like that's what the jets hope to have
in zach wilson and now here comes mike
white is that a problem well i guess
he's and solid saying it's not it's not
awkward it's awesome do you agree with
that okay could be this way too i'll
give you another
guest for i was just talking about like
the late rounder or the guy nobody knew
of becoming the guy because he became
the guy in the redskins
to answer your question about you need
the generational talent this is why i
don't think you play him right away i
i'm a total outlier here i know i'm like
one of
one person that still thinks situm but i
look at two of the generational talents
right now aaron rodgers and patrick
mahomes and they both sat
and zach wilson never should have
started he never should be playing right
away i mean and i said this in the draft
if you go back to the byu stuff he does
amazing flash and sizzle stuff you
cannot argue with the talent it was
jaw-dropping at times and it was equally
jaw-dropping when he passed open
hundreds of wide receivers that were
white ass open standing right in front
of him to go do something spectacular
and the same exact thing happened when
he started playing for the jets is he's
passing up these open players to go try
to do something better and maybe he
needs to sit for a year and watch mike
white just deal just run the offense
execute play at a high level make a play
here and there and go oh that's how tom
brady's played for 48 years and won 12
super bowls he just plays the position
like a professional until zach wilson
learns to play the position like a
professional which a lot of us
don't really ever figure out i'll be one
of them it took me until my body was
broken to figure out how to play it like
a professional but until you learn how
to play like a professional you're not
going to be consistent and consistency
is what is great in the nfl not flash
and sizzle the flash and sizzle comes
out if you're special four to eight
times a game if you're not special two
to four times a game
you are the best trent dilfer love you
best your wife good luck tonight let's
do this again appreciate you rich
anytime right back at you that's trent
dill for at dilfer's dimes
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here